c'est bien connu le travail mais le
travail peut aussi l'altérer nuisances
sonores charges lourdes fumée poussière
voilà qui constitue des éléments de
tennie limité c'est une chose qui est
très très pénibles de travailler comme
cela parce que nous soulevons des choses
très très lourdes il a fallu du temps
avant que la pénibilité soit prise en
compte dans la carrière d'un employé à
la fin des années 60 et 70
c'est un enjeu au sein de l'entreprise
quand arrêter le travail
à cette époque l'âge légal de départ en
retraite est fixé à 65 ans les usines
les chantiers les champs certaines
professions portés par leur syndicat
demande à partir à 60 ans j'aurais bien
voulu avoir ma retraite maintenant 60
ans en 1983 l'âge de départ en retraite
en france passe à 60 ans c'est une
mesure phare du président françois
mitterrand
l'ong revendications socialiste
notamment en raison de la pénibilité au
travail demandant le droit à la retraite
à 60 ans en 2011 la réforme des
retraites sous la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy porte cet âge à soixante deux
ans une exception cela dit pour les
salariés usés par le travail
ils peuvent partir à 60 ans en cas
d'incapacité de travail de 20 % qui dit
usure physique du constat médical
donc à partir de 20 % vous aurez la
possibilité et le droit de partir à la
retraite dès 60 ans en deçà entre 10 et
20% d'incapacité
il faut justifier d'un critère de
pénibilité c'est la première fois que la
loi définit la pénibilité il y a dix
critères au total comme le travail de
nuit
l'exposition chimiques les postures
pénibles ou le bruit
le 1er janvier 2015 le gouvernement
socialiste instaure à son tour le conte
pénibilité le salariés exposés à un ou
plusieurs critères cumul des points qui
lui permettront d'acheter des trimestres
et donc de partir en retraite plus tôt
chez les patrons avant même la mise en
place ça ne passe pas un salarié qui va
fait effectuer une tâche répertorié
parmi ces 10 fonction dite peinée devra
être traqué heure par heure et sur un
suivi quotidien par le chef d'entreprise
c'est une machine absolument infernal
c'est aussi grave que les 35 heures en
le conte pénibilité a été simplifié le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe a
supprimé 4 des 10 critères les charges
lourdes
les postures pénibles les vibrations
mécaniques et les risques chimiques
trop compliqué à évaluer selon le
patronat prisonniers du boulot pas de
vieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]